when I heard is knees next anime a
feature was gonna be Tarzan I remember
thing to myself yeah that sounds about
right I mean it is a pretty well-known
subject matter it does lend itself to
animation and at the same time I was
wondering if it might have the same
impact that Robin Hood had you know
where people would actually be
introduced to it through the Disney
version as opposed to other forms of
media
I saw the trailers and got really
excited for it and when it came out a
lot of it exceeded my expectations while
other parts fo were kind of mediocre ok
well let's jump right in
a family is shipwrecked on an island and
they find they have to live on their own
but unfortunately a cheetah comes and
kills the parents leaving only the baby
behind coincidentally the exact same
cheetah kills the child of an ape family
and when you know it they happen to bump
into each other so the mother ape
decides she wants to look after the
child but the father ape is not quite as
positive so growing up the little boy
Tarzan has to not only win out his
friends who he seems to be an outcast in
front of but also his father who seems
to want nothing to do with him
once he grows into a man he comes across
some more people a hunter named Clayton
a bumbling little professor and his
daughter named Jane Jane and Tarzan
immediately start to hit it off and Jane
starts to show him all about the human
world while he starts to show her all
about the animal world the romance is
born and of course an evil villain is
discovered ok so what's good about the
movie
well the animation I mean yeah look at
what they can do with Tarzan is
unbelievable before this people would
just associate him with swinging around
on vines but look at this he's
practically surfing the trees that's
really creative Tarzan himself is a
pretty decent character I mean he does
all the stuff you want to do each snarl
he sneers he roars but he does have
those big puppy-dog eyes and he does
manage to be sentimental at certain
moments Jane is my example of a damsel
in distress done right I mean yeah not
every character has to be strong not
every character has to be wielding a
sword but they have to at least be
interesting and Jane despite the fact
that she has to be saved all the time is
interesting she's polite but she's
eccentric she's clumsy but she's got a
good heart
and it sort of makes sense that she'd
had to be saved all the time I mean
she's out of her environment and this is
very much how women were like at that
time period but she still contributes in
being the education for Tarzan and also
the emotional center so yeah I think
she's a fun character Rosie O'Donnell
does an ape and yeah I won't say ideal
casting cuz let's face it everybody else
already has and while she is annoying
she's not as annoying as she could have
been waiting and I don't think I'm
giving anything away here is obviously
the bad guy he's kind of like Gaston
except - any of the comedy or charm he's
not very interesting and his motivation
is as boring as the Disney motivation
yet it's just greed it's the Pocahontas
villain all over again the motivation is
boring he's boring it slows everything
down the rest of the side characters are
kind of forgettable but to be fair they
keep the focus where it should be on
Tarzan the songs are by Phil Collins
wait what
foo cows what does he have to do with
Disney your jungles or anything like
that well okay maybe he'll write some
good songs for the characters to sing oh
no they're not singing at all
he's just singing the songs right though
fuck out of nowhere every time you start
singing I expect all the animals to
start looking around saying fuck is that
sometimes the orchestration surround the
songs can be nice but the actual songs
themselves they don't do a thing for me
it I guess he's sort of sings about
what's going on but kind of in the same
way that hey this can be played on the
radio as well it's all too vain if the
songs not totally invested in what it's
singing about so why should we but I
think my main issue with the movies the
conflict that Tarzan is going through
which don't get me wrong it is there and
it is addressed and they do take time
out of the movie to look at it but I
just wish they took more time I was kind
of thinking to myself Wow Disney
Animation and the turmoil of Tarzan what
they can do with this half-man
half-animal I mean there's so many
different variations you can do with
animation it sounds sort of thinking of
something along the lines of Hellfire
like visually showing the turmoil that
the person is going through as well as a
musical form you know it's supposed to
Phil Collen singing yeah Tarzan tear
yeah oh wait no not Tarzan cuz I'd be
too specific ah
and feeling something that this
characters feeling too near fuck the
cult but instead it's sort of fighting
for room with the comic relief and the
villain and again the Phil Collen songs
and I don't know I guess I just want
much more of that to be the focus even
the romance between Tarzan and Jane
couldn't that explore it a little bit
more I mean I guess it works alright but
again it feels like they're trying to
squeeze in too much that's not totally
needed like its childhood you could have
really gone into him trying to fit in
and yeah they do but it's mostly played
for laughs I like the scene where he
tries to cover himself in mud and terms
off into an eighth but that's only for a
few seconds and the same thing when he
meets Jane for the first time he takes
off her glove touches a human hand for
the first time and it's a nice scene but
again it's only a few seconds I guess I
wanted more of his internal struggle to
take up the majority of the film but
then again it is Disney I mean I can't
expect all the characters to be like
Frollo and Hunchback of Notre Dom I mean
maybe I'm just getting spoiled just this
thought that Disney wants to give better
and better and in many respects they are
so when a Disney film doesn't take
advantage of a really great opportunity
especially when it looks like you only
have one shot at it it's kind of a
letdown especially when it's just thrown
away to the same greedy plot device that
the villain provides you know what
they're in the jungle why do they need a
villain everything's already trying to
get them in fact why didn't they make
the cheetah the villain he's the one
that killed a kid a pair of parents like
when they make that like a sheer con
tied villain that would have been so
much more interesting but again I'm
probably trying to see it for what I
want it to be as opposed to what it is
for what it is that's good the animation
has some great moments I do like our two
main characters if there is actually
time set aside for character development
just not as much as I would like on the
whole Tarzan is a good flick to check
out so the next time you see it on DVD
keep it in rent
you probably enjoy it
you